why are you so obsessed with me that's a
good question because as mean as Regina
is we have to admit we're obsessed
we love rooting for the hero but let's
take a moment to appreciate some classic
female villains is Miranda Priestly
really the devil and to share got a pass
for her clueless behavior yes we're
going to start out with the meanest
fictional gal around Miranda Priestly
just how bad is she well she's in a
movie called The Devil Wears Prada and
let's just say she has some expensive
tastes you have no style or sense of
fashion
although author Lauren Weisberger claims
Aranda is not based on notoriously
particular vogue editor-in-chief Anna
Wintour you don't have to search hard to
find similarities between them when this
movie came out a lot of fans couldn't
help but compare her to nuclear winter a
nickname she hates by the way Miranda is
cold calculating and possibly the worst
boss anyone could have the misfortune of
working for sure she's a smart shrewd
woman who knows her stuff that her vast
amounts of fashion knowledge doesn't
exactly help improve morale around the
office you're wearing a sweater that was
selected for you by the people in this
room although Andy loses herself trying
to impress Miranda the products ad devil
doesn't change at all and remains one of
these Sassy's characters of all time now
let's talk about the meanest girl from
the appropriately titled movie Mean
Girls how many of you have ever felt
personally victimized by Regina George
there's no doubt Regina is popular
people think she's often when she
punches them in the face but she's also
undoubtedly the worst
beware of the plastics not only does
Regina rule the school with an iron fist
but nobody is safe from her
manipulations she isn't even loyal to
her own friends who are desperate for
the smallest bit of kindness from Regina
the meaner Regina was to her the more
Gretchen tried to win Regina back that
only does Regina verbally spar below the
belts but to make matters worse she's
totally two-faced she'll smile at the
folks at school and then let them have
it in her burn look or under her breath
as they walk away that is the ugliest
effing skirt I've ever seen that only is
Regina downright cruel but she has
serious issues managing her anger even
being hit
a bus could barely break her stride
hopefully playing lacrosse helps her
work through some of her clearly serious
issues I'm a little crazy
Nancy downs from the craft isn't the
most popular girl in school by a
longshot but not being part of the
plastics doesn't necessarily make you a
nice person not only does Nancy have
some serious issues but she has the
power to back up her anger at the world
and anyone she thinks does her wrong
you're a witch even before she got a
serious power boost
via an ancient ritual she was the
definition of sassy and she didn't
hesitate to use her magic for evil
giving the slightest motivation she hung
out with people willing to let her be
the boss and couldn't stand the idea of
things not going her way that is
terrible and downright spooky as Nancy
can be you can feel at least a little
bad for her considering she didn't have
the easiest life she's a little bit of
power okay a lot of power go to her head
nobody was safe from Nancy's ego her
need for control or her desire for a
revenge not even the people she once
called her friends imagine how different
Mean Girls would have been if Regina
could have cast spells in the Princess
Diaries rewatched Mia Thermopolis go
from awkward high school students to a
slightly less awkward princess but while
Mia underwent some major changes the
same can't be said for her classmate
Lana Thomas she knows just how shy and
unhappy Mia is and uses her popularity
and confidence to make her as miserable
as possible Lana seems to have it all
money looks talent and friends whose
names rhyme with hers but the one thing
she doesn't have is kindness or any kind
of redemption art
Lana is unrepentantly awful tamiya but
in the books they actually go on to
become friends but since we're strictly
talking about the movies here she's
still one of the meanest fictional girls
around actress Mandy Moore said she'd be
open to reprising the role as long as
Lana could be somehow redeemed she'd
love to add some backstory about ha Lana
was insecure herself and see her come to
regret the way she treated me a-- josh
is such an idiot we're gonna make sure
no one bothers you
Olive penderghast learned how quickly a
couple of white lies can spiral out of
control in the movie easy a she lied
about hooking up causing a rift between
her and her bestie an inspiring her
classmate Marianne Bryant to go on a
warpath I'm not the one that you have to
answer to for your depraved behavior
that only is Marianne an absolute bully
but she tries to pretend her actions are
motivated by caring and compassion when
that couldn't be further from the truth
I love you guys God loves you guys
no let's change lives today she uses her
beliefs as an excuse for bad behavior
and is totally judgmental towards olive
about something that wouldn't be any of
her business
even if it was true Marianne wasn't even
honest about her own spiteful mean
nature and made it her mission to make
olive as miserable as possible maybe
next time a certain somebody will be a
little more careful what she says in the
water closet the only slightly
mitigating factor here is that Marianne
was secretly just as miserable as she
tried to make olive she held herself to
a set of impossibly high standards and
felt an enormous amount of pressure to
be perfect at all times that's enough to
make anyone lose their cool we're not
giving Mary Ann a pass for her bad
behavior but it's possible she's not as
outright evil as some of the other Mean
Girls we've found I really want us to be
friends can we please be friends legally
blonde is an absolute classic but not
everything in the film has aged well
like Elle declaring Enrique isn't
straight because of the way he dresses
seriously else not cool however a lot of
the movie is sadly still relevant today
including issues faced by both Elle and
Vivienne Kensington while L might look
like a member of the plastics she's
pretty much the nicest person you could
ever hope to meet you know if you would
come to a rush party I would have it
nice to you meanwhile wealthy Vivian
makes it her mission to make Elle as
miserable as possible she might not wear
pink but she manages to torment and
embarrass her rival do you think it's
acceptable that ms Woods is not prepared
no but even though L is an angel most of
the time let's not forget she was trying
to steal Vivian's fiancé do you remember
when we spent those four amazing hours
in the hot tub after winter formal not
only that the Vivian was under an
intense amount of pressure and was
forced to work twice as hard to get half
as much respect as her male co-workers
while L made navigating Harvard look
effortless Vivian was also willing to
admit she was wrong about Elle and was
smart enough to dump that jerk corner
but there's one word we'd used to
describe big red from bring it on it
would be ruthless although she might
have some other adjectives she prefers
being head cheerleader isn't easy
especially when you're determined to be
the absolute best Big Red's merciless
coaching style may have won her
competitions but it didn't win her many
friends in fact even to her fellow
cheerleaders she's an indomitable force
and her squad has no love loss for her
no matter how many times she dragged
them to victory big red has no feelings
honestly the only redeemable thing about
big red is that she was upfront about
how awful she is instead of trying to
hide it like characters such as Regina
George
not only was big red a bully to her own
teammates but she was even worse to
rival cheerleading squad the clovers she
stole the routines and was unremorseful
when her crimes were brought to life if
I made any mistake as squad leader it
wasn't far away Cheers
we know all's fair in love and
cheerleading but big red definitely took
things way too far
Britney this is not a democracy it's a
cheer ah cracy okay so technically this
gaggle of girls from never been kissed
isn't a solo mean girl but Gibby
Christin and Kirsten do tend to operate
as a single unit and collectively they
were really unkind to anyone they
thought was less popular and fashionable
than they were which was a surprisingly
high number of people including Josie
Geller
here's
kristan Gibby what's up girlfriend for
most of the movie these girls were just
kind of petty and as much as we hate to
admit it sometimes they weren't exactly
wrong with their fashion assessments I
know like five chickens had to die just
so she could look that stupid butt at
prom these gals really went over-the-top
when they seemed to cover
Aldys with a can of dog food seriously
it's like a way less intense version of
Stephen King's Carrie
luckily Josie managed to step up and
give these girls a stern lecture about
their actions you will spend your lives
trying to figure out how to keep others
down because it makes you feel more
important it seems like they turned
around after being dressed down by Josie
and we're willing to chalk up their mean
girl ways to them being young
impressionable and struggling to think
for themselves it can be hard not to
hate unspoiled amber Von Tussle in
either version of the hairspray movie
she's just plain awful to Tracy and is
too stuck up to see past her own nose at
least most of the time but you have to
admit she had the deck stacked against
her as far as parents go her mom is
overbearing cold and intolerant of other
people overcoming that kind of
upbringing is hard and it's impressive
that Amber was able to recognize her
mother's faults and strive to become a
better person
amber may have been a bully at one point
but she made her mission to be more than
that in this case the movie title
clueless pretty much says it all about
the main character cher she grew up
completely indulged by her rich father
and bonded with her Bessie Dion over the
fact that everyone is jealous of them
don't get us wrong cher starts up being
super judgmental of everyone else around
her and thinks she's better than her
peers but really she's just completely
out of touch with reality and doesn't
realize there's more than one way to be
fabulous cher just needed a little push
in the right direction to realize
helping others is more rewarding than
hurting them and she has more to offer
than just her looks to tell you the
truth I have not seen such good doing
since your mother who is your favorite
fictional mean girl and do you think she
falls on the classy too sassy spectrum
share your pic with us and your fellow
fans in the comment section below and
then click subscribe for more videos
from us here at the things thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time